precisamente el día de hoy una corte
británica ha manifestado existen
garantías suficientes para que llegue
más al puedo hacer este estado de eeuu
sin embargo esa decisión nuestra en
firme porque usted mismo ya lo ha
manifestado existen todavía
apelaciones que realiza precisamente hay
dos ante la corte suprema en gran
bretaña y otro ante un tribunal superior
por lo tanto esto todavía hay un camino
por recorrer recuerde usted que
aproximadamente hace un año se inició
este proceso de impugnación de apelación
y confiamos en que ella las decisiones
finales sean favorables a señor asas de
ahí confiar en que se garantice su
integridad físicos y colores en eeuu
pero que las audiencias previas a esta
decisión se ha demostrado que no
corresponde a una realidad